on today's episode it's a hotbed of
Hollywood hunker II but who is the
biggest Hollywood hotshot Brad vs. Leo
they're currently on top in Tinseltown
and this epic matchup takes place once
upon a time in Hollywood aah
it's the name of the movie anyway here's
how it works
round 1 box-office round 2 tomato meter
round 3 awards and we'll do a wild-card
round then you will determine the winner
one will continue to be an a-list actor
and the other is doomed to a fate of
summer stock forevermore let's get it on
I got a six pack in the back that we'd
order at each side one box office Brad
Pitt has had a longer career than the
Leo and it has accrued more total
dollars at the Cineplex so does that
mean he wins this round or is he just
older lies Brad's lifetime domestic holo
stands at four point two nine billion
dollars while Leo's is three point six
four billion let's take a closer look
that pits eight second cameo in Deadpool
- that total number for him slides down
to three point nine eight billion
dollars and Leo has a much higher per
movie average a hundred fifty two
million dollars for him a hundred and
ten million for Brad so is it quantity
over quality if you're asking me about
french fries the answer is always yes
when it comes to movies I like a fella
who has a guaranteed smash hit every
time Brad has made 39 flicks and some
real gems in there but Leo he's only
done 24 movies and he throws a haymaker
with every new talkie he releases I did
the best somebody here did the math and
by the time Leo is sixty and Brad Pitt
has turned into a little wrinkly baby
DiCaprio will overtake him at the box
office
so DiCaprio wins the round and he's up
1-nothing
[Music]
round two tomato meter well if it's
quality you want look no further than
the caliber of film these gentlemen put
out gratzi they're both the rare actor
that can brag about having a career
fresh average on the tomato meter
Brad's films rate sixty four point five
percent on average Leo trails and by
only a couple points at sixty two point
eight percent both these fellows tie for
highest individual movie score at 95%
Brad earned his for 12 years of slave
Leo for catch me if you can would you
like a drink after take off milk Brad
wasn't the star of his movie but he
didn't produce it and he won an Oscar
for it it is a fact plain and simple
fact that what is true and right is true
in life all so what are the films that
are weighing the boys down well Leo has
a big fat goose egg on his resume that
being for critters 3 you can't expect us
to believe this horseshit it's at 0%
that's not his fault he was like 9
Brad's Lois is 4 percent for cool world
and I am shocked it took me that long to
reference that classic remember cool
world that 4% would be a lot higher if
Who Framed Roger Rabbit hadn't already
come out no I'm getting the word know
that prey on that movie is still
terrible this round comes down to who's
been doing it better for longer I got
Pitt by the slightest of margins in both
regards Brad eats out of victory in this
round and we're tied at one apiece
cousin business is a-boomin round three
Awards look movies are fun and all but
we know they're not worth anything
unless they win a trophy same goes for
actors and both these thuds have built
quite a resume Brad Pitt you know how
many total Awards this guy's won 67 67
he's two away from Bill and Ted's
favorite number of all-time
69 teens and he's been nominated a
hundred and fifty-two times the guy from
cool world has won 67 award
well good luck competing this category
leo I'm sorry what's that boys and girls
I'm just getting word Leonardo DiCaprio
has won 97 Awards he's been nominated
209 times so he's more nominations more
wins and a better Nam to win ratio than
Brad but how about with the important
Awards there's one ceremony that stands
head and shoulders above the others
however each fella is tied with four MTV
Movie Awards so let's go to the lowly
Oscars instead Leo finally took home
Oscar gold with his win for the revenant
two years before Brad got his first
Oscar for producing 12 years of slave so
they're tied with one win apiece and six
nominations each but Leo's have all come
from acting Brad has been nominated
thrice for acting thrice for producing
and what are we talking about here today
movie stardom producing is great like
you pick up a phone you say how are
things going on set I'm sure more goes
into it than that
but I'm giving the win to Leo because
he's won more times for acting wildcard
round acting ring dad's acting range
like it's easy to be a leading man when
you're good-looking but which actor has
the most range when it comes to a role
Brad or a Leo Leo first came to
prominence playing a mentally disabled
teenager in What's Eating Gilbert Grape
he would go on to play everything from a
drug-addicted basketball player to a
reclusive innovator to a maniac
stockbroker
[Applause]
and when he acts with kate winslet he
can either be a bored suburban husband
or really wet and cold good range kid
but let me tell you something about Brad
stoner psychopaths cult leader
bare-knuckle boxer thief outlaw Nazi
hunter and zombie slayer and he can do
all these things while eating a
tremendous amount of calories on-screen
Pitt has consumed almost 5,000 calories
on screen all told which is incidentally
my record at Golden Corral Leo does get
points for eating actual bison liver
like an actual Bison liver he ate it and
he was damn good jr. thief and growing
pains remember when he was on the TV
show but the winner of the round is the
man who is possibly the dumbest personal
trainer in the history of cinema mr.
Brad tip Oh like you're so plugged into
the intelligence so at the end of the
wild-card round we find ourselves in a
dead heat it's tied at 2 so my
tiebreaker will be based purely on my
gut and my gut is saying go with the guy
with the better ABS
this is no sleight Tullio but have you
seen Brad 6-pack seriously it's not even
fair the guy eats in every scene in
every movie he's ever been in and he
still looks like that Brad gets the win
as the biggest Hollywood hotshot it's
official old buddy has been that's what
losing sounds like but that's just my
superficial take the real judge is you
the viewer head to the comment section
right now and vote by telling us your
winner is it the guy from the beach or
the dude from Tree of Life
good luck understanding either one of
those films thanks for tuning in I'm
Mark Ellis and I will do no crunches
today
[Music]
[Applause]